salut aujourd'hui si vous êtes un vrai
mental au vous dites perdez donc il
habillé commis hier oui mais hier je
vous avais prévenu là ce soir peut être
pour la dernière fois en suisse pour mon
spectacle au cpe à auchy comme je ne
sais pas trop comment je vais avoir
internet etc
je prépare cette ville était aussi à
l'avance au cas où est donc si vous
voyez c'est que j'ai pas pu en faire une
autre là bas et du coucher en train de
rentrer dans un paradoxe temporel
terrible aujourd'hui je vais vous donner
des petites choses qui m'a mise
particulièrement sur les nombres les
chiffres et les codes cachés qui le
représente
ne fuyez pas c'est intéressant
les nombres et les chiffres sont partout
autour de nous depuis notre plus tendre
enfance quand on nous raconte un compte
il ya souvent comme élément fort un
chiffre blanche neige et les sept nains
les trois petits cochons mais trois
mousquetaires ils sont aussi toujours
intimement lié au jeu au morpion il faut
avoir trois fois le même symbole quand
on joue avec dédé bon là on est purement
dans les chiffres
les filles qui jouent à la marelle
également et si on se renseigne un petit
peu on se rend compte également que les
formes anciennes de langage était basé
sur les nombres et les chiffres c'est le
cas pour la poésie des trc avec trois
vers celle des 4 1 ou lassés des
strophes de 4 vers les pentes à mettre
où on a des verts qui sont composées de
cinq pieds les thermomètres
non là c'est une graine est par contre
il existe les exams être si on prend un
jeu de cartes par exemple où là on se
dit un jeu de cartes ok c'est très
classique dans un jeu de cartes ya 52
cartes est dans une année il ya 52
semaines
autre chose intéressante il ya quatre
familles piqueur car au trèfle est dans
une année il ya quatre saisons il ya
deux couleurs les rouges et les noirs
est dans une année il ya la période qui
est plutôt froide et la période plutôt
chaude si on fait la somme d'un jeu de
cartes as valant 1 le cas de vos quatre
le disco 10 avec le valet de la dame et
le roi valant 11 12 et 13
on fait la somme de toutes les cartes
des 52 cartes ça nous donne 364 si on
ajoute le premier joker s'adonne 365 le
nombre de jours qui redonne une année et
si on ajoute le deuxième joker ça nous
fait 366 comme le nombre de jours dans
une année bissextile comme cette année
autre chose intéressante en français
comme dans beaucoup de langues si on
compte le nombre de lettres qu'il faut
utiliser pour écrire 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 vallée des rois as ce nombre de
lettres là et 2,52 si on se concentre
sur les figures le valais la dame et le
roi il y en a douze comme le nombre de
mois qu'on a dans une année il ya un
petit côté cosmique en fait dans la
création du jeu de cartes qu'on retrouve
dans d'autres jeux d'ailleurs dans le
jeu de go également il ya un côté
création cosmique puisque le 18 et le 19
au jeu de go pour ceux qui connaissent
renvoie au cycle du soleil et de la lune
et comme les règles de la plupart de nos
jeux sont intrinsèquement liées au
nombre et aux chiffres on se rend compte
que quand on associe les deux dans les
règles il ya des choses cachées qui ont
été voulus ou pas j'en sais rien mais si
vous prenez par exemple un cavalier et
que vous lui faites des déplacements
infinie sur un échiquier de 64 cases en
numérotant les cases en fonction du
parcours et du nombre de fois où passe
le cavalier vous allez créer des carrés
magiques
si j'arrive à trouver une image de ça
sur internet vous allez de l'avant un
incruste maintenant par là je pense
et sinon je couperai la séquence pour
tout vous avouer je pourrais vous parler
des nombres et des chiffres et des codes
cachés qui renferme durant des heures je
sais pas si ça vous intéresse
particulièrement pour moi c'est lié
aussi à ma manière de faire le
mentalisme cette compréhension là des
choses qui sont cachés et qu'on peut
comprendre uniquement en étudiant les
choses qui composent ce qui est caché
je me pose sur ce soit bien clair cette
phrase si vous voulez qu'on en parle un
peu plus vous pouvez m'en parler dans
les commentaires je lis systématiquement
les commentaires je suis répond un petit
peu moins qu'avant c'est vrai mais quoi
qu'il arrive je les lis systématiquement
même les commentaires qui disent ah
ouais c'est vrai tu les lits et ben si
tu dis répond à ce message
non j'y réponds pas parce que je sais
que si je commence à faire ça alors là
je vais en avoir des centaines d comme
ça mais si ça vous dit que je fasse une
ou deux vidéos peut-être un peu plus
longues sur le sujet je le ferai avec
grand plaisir c'est une passion j'espère
en tout cas que cette vidéo là vous aura
plu
et si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
également à vous abonner avant de partir
puisque le mental boxe et une vidéo par
jour pendant un an
donc rendez vous demain à 11 heures eh
oui ciao
là haut
et